Добрий день, дорогі друзі!
Я, Олександр Авраменко, сьогодні проведу інтегрований урок
разом із популярним українським співаком Артемом Пивоваровим.
Наше заняття присвячене Дню української писемності та мови, який відзначаємо 27 жовтня.
Це свято розвитку державної мови,
день вшанування пам’яті Преподобного Нестора Літописця
послідовника творців слов’янської писемності Кирила й Мефодія.
Друзі, силу слова й силу письма важко переоцінити,
адже кожен наш день починається зі спілкування з рідними,
потім — із друзями й учителями в школі (це усне мовлення),
ми щодня пишемо SMS-повідомлення, спілкуємося в соцмережах (а це писемне мовлення).
Ми дивимося фільми, читаємо книжки, слухаємо пісні (а це читання, слухання, аудіювання).
Усе це — сприйняття й продукування інформації за допомогою мови.
Слово завжди відігравало важливу роль у складні історичні моменти нашої країни.
Тож письменники в усі історичні епохи надихали нас своїм поетичним словом,
давали нам надію, дарували естетичне задоволення.
Сьогодні пропонуємо погортати поетичні сторінки
Тараса Шевченка, Павла Тичини, фольклору
і послухати сучасні музичні інтерпретації.
Це тема нашого уроку. І почнемо з Тараса Шевченка.
Його називають пророком українського народу.
Зазирнімо до словника і з’ясуймо, хто такий пророк.
Читаю: «Пророк — провісник майбутнього».
А й справді, ментальна Тарасова засторога щодо москалів,
тобто росіян, з’являється в перших рядках поеми «Катерина».
Пригадуєте «Кохайтеся, чорнобриві, та не з москалями. Бо москалі — чужі люде, роблять лихо з вами»?
І хоч у поемі йдеться про Катерину, яку зганьбив москаль,
проте літературознавці розглядають образ цієї жінки-покритки як алегоричний,
тобто образ України, поневоленої і приниженої росією.
Поет переймався важкою долею рідного народу й викладав свої переживання, думки на папері:
«Думи мої, думи мої, лихо мені з вами! Нащо стали на папері сумними рядами?..»
От цікаво ця поезія зазвучала в інтерпретації Артема Пивоварова і Наді Дорофєєвої.
До речі, цей музикант створив цілий проєкт по-сучасному переспіваних творів нашої класики.
Він має назву «Твої вірші, мої ноти».
Вітаю, Артеме! Дякую за цікавий проєкт.
У ньому 18 пісень, але найбільше переглядів на ютубі (понад 42 мільйони, друзі!)
має ваша інтерпретація вірша «Думи мої, думи мої…».
Артеме, от на вашу думку, у чому секрет успіху саме цієї пісні?
Вітаю, Олександре!
По-перше, хочу привітати всіх учнів та вчителів.
Дякую, що запросили мене. Честь бути присутнім на цьому уроці.
Я радію тому факту, що на сьогоднішній день українська музика виходить на світовий рівень.
тому що не кожен закордонний артист може говорити про такі результати.
І 42 мільйони переглядів — це результат єднання мільйонів українських жовто-блакитних сердець
в поєднанні з пророчими словами Тараса Григоровича, які й сьогодні відгукуються в цих серцях.
Як красиво! Як естетично звучить поезія в музиці!
А як тонко поети передають пейзажі, створюючи дивовижні художні образи!
Сьогодні в українців за вікном різні пейзажі, бо війна розкидала нас по всьому світу.
І якими б не були ароматними фінські хвойні ліси,
і як би не тішили око екзотичні іспанські чи італійські краєвиди, український пейзаж найрідніший.
Знаю, що наш урок зараз дивляться багато українських дітей за кордоном.
Тож хочу вам сказати, що нашу смереку, калину, вербу, тополю ніщо не замінить, бо вони свої, рідні.
Недарма поети й народ у фольклорних творах оспівує ці дерева.
До прикладу, Павло Тичина — наш кларнетист, майстер музикальної поезії
— творить українські синьо-жовті пейзажі з неба і поля, і, звичайно ж, тут і місце тополі:
«Де тополя росте, серед поля стою. І шумить, і співа жито думку свою. Шумить жито, співа, заохочує жить».
Взагалі, тополя — дерево-символ. А символ має велике значення.
Скажімо, вишитий рушник символізує життєву дорогу, батьківську оселю.
Пригадайте «Пісню про рушник»: «Рідна мати моя, ти ночей не доспала…»
І перекладіть іноземцям, наприклад, англійською «А song about a towel».
Без цього символізму назва сприймається так само пісно, як пісня про простирадло чи пісня про наволочку.
Тож повернімося до тополі як символу — це важливо.
Тополя може бути: символом оберегу українців; символом рідної землі, тобто тополя — це Україна;
і символом дівочої і жіночої краси, стрункості, а водночас і смутку, самотності.
Але цікавий не лише пейзаж.
Ліричний герой Тичини серед рідної природи ділиться своїми переживаннями, душевним станом:
«В моїм серці і бурі, і грози, й рокотання-ридання бандур…»,
— які алітерації! Тут передчуття чогось буремного.
Дуже несподіване й цікаве прочитання цього символу — і не тільки його — дає Артем Пивоваров,
поєднавши два вірші Тичини про тополю.
Ну а що з цього вийшло, ви зараз почуєте. Так, Артеме, ваша пісня «Там у тополі» дуже ритмічна.
Чому саме такий ритм ви вибрали? І як взагалі народилася така ідея?
Перед тим, як відповісти на ваші запитання, я хочу, як і ви, зауважити, що Павло Тичина у своїх творах
дуже влучно передає кожну деталь і символіку нашого народу та українських краєвидів.
Я завжди, створюючи музику, відштовхуюся від внутрішнього відчуття.
Читаючи ці два вірші в момент створення, я відчував і усвідомлював
той буйний вітер, вихор та, як ви вже попередньо наголошували, рокотання та ридання бандур.
Тому відчуваючи у своїм серці і бурі, і грози,
я не міг не написати й не обрати саме таку динамічну лірику та не створити таку потужну композицію.
Як важливо кожній людині бути кимось потрібним, бути з кимось, не самому.
Тож кожен із нас шукає своє щастя, свою любов, із якою буде йти по життю разом.
У народних піснях закоханих молодих часто зображають у вигляді птахів — скажімо, голуба й голубки,
як у народній пісні «Ой там на горі». Пісня дуже колоритна. Згадайте цей фрагмент.
У житті буває так, що пару закоханих розлучають непереборні обставини.
Скажімо, прилітає хижий птах, наприклад, сокіл, і забирає, знищує коханого.
А кохана лишається сама, як та голубка в пісні «Ой там на горі». Артеме, у вас є своя версія цієї пісні.
У коментарі, до речі,  до кліпу ви написали, що (цитую)
«оригінальна версія пісні пронизана журбою і несе сумну енергетику,
нова ж (ваша версія), — сповнена світла та надії».
У чому проявляється це світло, надія: у ритмах, у настрої?
Безумовно, у цій пісні присутня надпотужна енергетика.
На сьогоднішній день я усвідомлюю, що кожен українець та українка потрібні своїй країні як ніколи.
Ми відстоюємо нашу айдентику, нашу культуру. Музика — також наша зброя.
Саме тому мені в моїй інтерпретації народної пісні захотілося
передати й показати світові наш войовничий та бойовий дух.
Ця пісня, до речі, була випущена однією з перших на момент повномасштабного вторгнення,
і я в той момент усвідомлював, що ця музика має бути квінтесенцією найкращих якостей наши захисників.
Саме тому в ній присутні бойові ритми, потужна енергія та надія на світле майбутнє.
Сподіваюся, вам сподобалися сучасні музичні інтерпретації нашої класики від Артема Пивоварова.
А зараз настав час для невеликого тесту.
Пропоную перевірити, як кожен із вас засвоїв сьогоднішній матеріал. Отож уперед!
Перше. У пісні «Ой там на горі» немає художнього образу: А — голубки; Б — сокола; В — тополі; Г — крил.
Візьміть ручку та запишіть біля цифри 1 правильну відповідь.
Впоралися? Завдання друге.
Тополя в українців може символізувати усе перелічене, окрім: А — оберегу українців; Б — закоханої пари; В — дівочої краси; Г — рідної землі.
Переходимо до третього завдання.
У пісні «Ой там на горі» немає мотиву: А — людської ніжності; Б — розлуки закоханих; В — насильства ззовні; Г — майбутнього дітей. Подумайте.
Так, четверте завдання.
Постійний епітет наявний у фрагменті: А — З буйним вітром, свавольним і диким!; Б — Моя пісне, вогниста, шалена, шалена!;
В — Хтось на заході жертву приніс богам, напевно;
Г — В моїм серці і бурі, і грози, й рокотання-ридання бандур…
Виберіть епітет (постійний епітет) та запишіть правильну відповідь.
І переходимо до останнього, п’ятого завдання.
Правильним є твердження:
А — пісня Артема Пивоварова «Думи» написана за мотивами однойменного твору Павла Тичини;
Б — у пісні «Думи» ліричний герой хотів би, аби його сумні думки, переживання розвіяв вітер;
В — пісня «Думи», як і вірш «Думи мої, думи мої…», належить до пейзажної лірики;
Г — пісня «Думи» починається із заклику до чорнобривих не кохатися з москалями.
Так, вибрали правильну відповідь? Ну що, впоралися з тестом? Готові перевіряти себе? Отож почнімо.
Правильні відповіді такі: 1 — В (у пісні «Ой там на горі» немає образу тополі);
2 — Б (тополя не символізує закоханої пари);
3 — Г (у пісні «Ой там на горі» немає мотиву майбутнього дітей);
4 — А (постійний, або фольклорний епітет — буйний вітер);
5 — Б (у пісні «Думи» ліричний герой хотів би, аби його сумні думки, переживання розвіяв вітер).
Ну як результат? Сподіваюся, він високий.
Наша сьогоднішня розмова була про символи, художні образи, мотиви поезій,
про те, що українці здавна співають у піснях, а поети зображають у віршах,
про Шевченка й Тичину, про музику Артема Пивоварова, про війну, про наше життя.
Ми повинні знати: хто ми, українці, і чиї ми діти.
Ми маємо вивчати свою культуру й боронити її,
бо в наших піснях — ми з вами, наше життя, наша національна естетика й філософія.
А отже, те, що нас з вами об’єднує, — любов і свобода.
Ми з Артемом будемо завершувати свою частину уроку.
А час, який у вас лишився, радимо присвятити виконанню двох завдань.
Одне з них підготував я, а друге — Артем.
Отже, перше завдання (усне).
Візьміть участь у дискусії, висловивши думку щодо такого проблемного питання.
Нині, в епоху стрімкого розвитку цифрових технологій, людина все більше віддаляється від природи,
живого спілкування, віддаючи перевагу віртуальному.
Чи втратить із часом актуальність народна пісня, класична поезія — те, що передали нам наші предки?
Отже, втратить чи ні? Наведіть переконливі аргументи й приклади на користь своєї позиції.
І друге завдання, від Артема.
Моє завдання наступне: які з розглянутих у моєму проєкті «Твої вірші, мої ноти» поетів запам’яталися вам?
Хто сподобався як особистість і як автор? Можливо, загалом є поет або вірш, що сподобався вам?
Розкажіть, який і чому. Можливо, я розгляну його у своєму проєкті в майбутньому.
Ось і все. Насамкінець лише додам: вивчаймо мову, що передали нам наші предки!
І до наступних зустрічей!